my name is Jim Gaffigan and I'm doing
the wired autocomplete interview do I
just
eat this or I just start chewing what
Jim Gaffigan like so are cavemen typing
this in why can't someone put an
adjective in there what is Jim Gaffigan
in but what what is he in you know how
could he be in anything
what production would cast that guy what
is Jim Gaffigan doing now he obviously
isn't working what is he doing now
I wonder if he's homeless that's
probably the prompt like you know I bet
you Jim Gaffigan is homeless they're
like you know why don't you ask Google
what college did Jim Gaffigan go to that
seems kind of passive-aggressive like I
wonder what college let him in
Georgetown University John Mulaney went
there Mike Birbiglia I don't know if
this is true but I heard that Jesus went
there what position did Jim Gaffigan
play like what the assassination of JFK
what position was he on the grassy knoll
I played football in college don't be so
surprised all right I mean it was
Division three
I'm flattered because I feel like I look
like a lineman you know like people
would be like like would there be any
debate like I wonder if he was the tight
end or the quarterback like I would
think there wouldn't be a debate about
that am I doing this right yeah okay is
Jim Gaffigan a priest I mean I have five
children people are googling that you
know hey you know that guy that's Mary
with five kids that's a comedian that
tours around the country do you think
he's a priest is Jim Gaffigan Mormon
I've heard this before I do have a lot
of children so I can see that someone
would draw that conclusion
I did eight Marie Osmond for 25 years so
that might have something to do with it
I watched Big Love but you know that's
about it but I drink coffee
is Jim Gaffigan albino all right thanks
a lot but I am pale and I guess people
are curious I was always trying to add
an adjective before white so that people
would go hey that that really pale guy I
wanted them to go the really funny pale
guy it's Jim Gaffigan Canadian oh I like
that one I think that's a compliment
that's a compliment I feel so
international that's the most exotic I
could get right like you wouldn't be
like like no one would ever say that
about me but you might be like you know
he's a comedian you know a lot of
Canadians are comedians like this he's
nice I am NOT Canadian I'm from the
Midwest
but I do enjoy performing in Canada it's
Jim Gaffigan nice well if you think I'm
Canadian wouldn't you figure it was nice
maybe that the the process goes I wonder
if he's Canadian and then like he's not
Canadian yeah man I wonder if he's even
nice if I'm not Canadian and not nice
what am i alright is Jim Gaffigan
there's Jim Gaffigan a clean comedian
comedians do their act and then you
weirdos need to put us in categories
comedians do what they do and then they
get credit or criticism for the type of
comedy they do so it's like oh they're
so brave it's like yeah maybe they're
brave or they're just like that you're I
mean I guess I am clean but in some ways
that's
is Jim Gaffigan and Super Troopers if
you have to ask if I'm in Super Troopers
that's good because I would say most of
the people that know that I'm in Super
Troopers have yelled and said me out to
me I worked on the movie for two hours
and if I died today I'd be known as the
hot pocket meow guy it's Jim Gaffigan
dead in some ways on the inside very
much so when I die which believe me I'm
looking forward to it when I die is that
person that works in the funeral home
it's gonna be an easy gig like it's the
same complexion when I'm dead or alive
is Jim Gaffigan and Daniel Tosh friends
I've known all comedians forever while
they may have different views and maybe
approach different things I like them
there is a solidarity among comedians
because we have this strange desire to
go on stage and make strangers laugh so
comedians will often defend their fellow
comedians brothers and sisters like
relatives yes I am friends with Daniel
Tosh who Jim Gaffigan who is Jim
Gaffigan that's pretty standard right
whoo Jim Gaffigan
whoo-hoo-hoo Jim Gaffigan who does Jim
Gaffigan look like all right I get this
a lot and my apologies to Brad Pitt and
George Clooney a lot of people send me
pictures of cats that look like me I was
sent once a pillow that looked like me
who is Jim Gaffigan wife like is that
kind of like people are so shocked if
someone would marry me I'm just relieved
it's like is Jim Gaffigan wife blind
it's not one of those who did Jim
Gaffigan open for I opened for the Pope
but I didn't really open for the Pope I
opened for the popemobile so I opened
for an automobile like I did stand out
bombed in front of 2 million people
and then the popemobile drove into this
outdoor area so I opened for a car who
is Jim Gaffigan Hotel Transylvania 3
yeah I don't know that feels kind of
insulting like he was obviously some
monster which monster was he
I played van Helsing who's the the
monster killer you know I've got five
children so it was really excited to
bring my kids to see me and my
six-year-old who was five at the time
looked at me and he was like impressed
for like a moment and then he was like
can we get popcorn all right
don't put those there
does Jim Gaffigan does Jim Gaffigan
curse yeah I I do curse not constantly
but like if I stub my toe or I'm around
my children I'll curse a lot but I don't
necessarily curse if in my stand-up I am
a tool of Jesus I can't curse shoot see
I can does Jim Gaffigan drink alcohol I
do there was an extended period where I
did not because I was so focused on my
career and then I had children and I
needed to drink when I didn't drink
people would overreact they're like oh
you don't drink is it okay if I drink
that doesn't happen or oh you don't use
mayonnaise is it okay if I use mana
should I use the mayonnaise outside does
Jim Gaffigan have a brother I have three
brothers two sisters on the youngest of
six in my family I am considered third
funniest but I have a lot more comedy
specials than my siblings now who is
winning joe why does Jim Gaffigan have
five kids I do and frankly it's
something I regret I mean do you think I
would look like this if I had just one
kid no I have five kids by the way most
of my parenting responsibilities are
taking screens away from those children
that's it
that's all I do for parenting okay which
Jim Gaffigan which Jim Gaffigan which
Jim Gaffigan is hot pockets hot pockets
is a blessing and a curse I certainly
don't need more people just yelling it
at me whether it be drunk people after a
show or me just walking through an
airport and someone gone how pockets is
I don't know how to respond honestly I
don't know if I say how I got back or
thank you or sorry which Jim Gaffigan
special is best that's interesting I've
done seven two
of them are on Amazon five of them on
Netflix but I don't know I feel like I'm
getting better at stand-up which Jim
Gaffigan movie should I watch that's
encouraging because I love acting I love
working on films because you're creating
the character with the writer and
director and producers and I love the
collaborative atmosphere on a movie set
and that you can obsess on a character
and be a participant in a scene which
Jim Gaffigan will remember you you know
I'm not that smart but what does this
mean
see I poor eyesight and a bad memory but
I have poor eyesight and I also can be
seen from far away because I'm kind of
goofy-looking because I'm kind of
approachable I think people say hey Jim
like they're talking to a friend but I
might not have met them and then
sometimes maybe I met them or maybe
there are a parent of a child at one of
my children's school it's very complex
the only thing that really concerns me
is which Jim Gaffigan will remember me
like do I have a split personality
is there another me do you I mean I'm
just relieved that it's not just is Jim
Gaffigan gonna die from eating too much
yet
you